- We're a big group of strong women
that takes risks riding motorcycles
all the time in the City,
which takes a set of steel
ovaries, in my opinion.
But, we want to help babies.
Who says no to babies?
(dramatic music)
(gentle music)
The club delivers
processed and pasteurized
donor breast milk to
mothers and babies in need,
both to NICUs in hospitals
and to private homes.
We focus our service on
women's health issues,
so this is a complete fit for
what we try to do as a club.
The call for milk can come at any time.
You can be anywhere.
We pull up to the dock at
the New York Milk Bank.
- Hi!
- [Jennifer] Julie brings out the milk
that's been pre-packaged
in freezer bags and boxes.
We strap it down to the
motorcycles, zip away.
- When we opened up the Milk Bank,
I was actually stuck in
traffic with my husband
and saw a motorcycle rider
illegally driving up the center lane.
And I thought why can't
we use motorcyclists
to deliver milk in and out of New York?
We collect it from women that
have an excess amount of milk.
We process it, test it, and
distribute it to hospitals
for premature infants and
to the community at large.
- Up, good girl.
Marlowe was born four months early.
I brought Marlowe home
after 161 days in the NICU.
I stopped producing breast milk.
And all of Marlowe's
doctors required Marlowe
to continue on breast milk
because putting her on formula
would gravely endanger her life.
I had to find a way to be able
to give my daughter breast
milk and I found donor milk.
Since then, we've been getting deliveries
from the Milk Bank.
We get delivery once a month.
It's 330 bottles of three ounces.
The sound of those motorcycles
is the sound of hope.
Hi!
They're bringing life, liquid life,
for a small baby who they don't know.
Every time we give Marlowe a bottle,
I start to think about what's in there.
It's not just one woman's work.
I know the hard work, energy, labor,
love, dedication and sacrifice
that goes into every ounce.
We don't waste a drop around here.
It's priceless.
(uplifting music)